dude so i got turned on you from uh
simon rex such a nice guy
that's what you say yeah okay you you
don't you never
you don't know him no i want the other
side of the car oh you want the other
you want the door
the dark side on the dark side you want
that dark dirt i want that dirty soil
brother to
when i first moved to l.a before i moved
here yeah you should move out you should
move out here you move out of here yeah
i'm like i'm hyped up i'm like hollywood
life and getting ready
you go you know what i mean you see the
glitz and the glamour putting on lotion
all kind of tanning lotion that puts it
makes you dark while you sleep again
get barricades your pores with did you
see the butterscotch babes you think
are you thinking the hollywood you're
thinking the stars are all aligned
oh you got tits in your brain so i go so
he was all cool at first
once i finally went out there to live
he's like yeah you sure you could stay
with me and
i'm like okay well i mean sure well i'd
find a place and
everything i'll you sure i'll hang out
there you know i mean so i i i'm like
okay cool so
i'm thinking like you know you get there
you had luggage with you or whatever
i didn't even ask him how many rooms he
had he had about seven or eight rooms
because he said he stayed up in the
hills i don't know
i've never been there but i heard he so
he had a house yeah he had a house up
there in the hills
and i think like a few houses down was
uh
cindy crawford as a house all right so
so i'm at his house
i jerk off on the street if cindy
crawford lived by me you know
yeah so he he he has me moving i think
i'm gonna stay on the couch or one of
his rooms or something
he had he had a uh downstairs it was
like a three-story house so you go
downstairs
wow and then down there's a wine cellar
and he's like yeah you can have this
room but i'm seeing these racks on the
wall i'm like this is no
this isn't a room yeah it's for grapes
yeah this is for for the sun-dried
grapes
this is for aged prunes
so i go in there and i have a room and
i'm thinking
he let he didn't let me he would throw
parties he wouldn't let me come on
stairs because there was a door of the
lock
he'd like to have the part i'm seeing
the people come in damn yeah you had to
stay down there you got to stay down
i'm like damn yeah you're like in notre
dame like that guy that rings the bell
i'm not i'm the i didn't know i'll be
answering the door and that's about it
yeah
i thought i was gonna get the party with
the with the hollywood stars yeah
and so who came through there all types
of people huh bill cosby
reynolds burt reynolds wow yeah yeah uh
kevin costner i've seen
in and out he knew everybody yeah uh jim
tome
dan you know jim tome chipper jones
stopped by a couple times
jesus yeah and who else even i heard
that they had daffy duck passed through
no no more gossip garcia para he go he
ghosted me a couple of times on a
handshake on the way out
yeah so i was trying to catch girls
coming out trying to talk to him that
like
that big jump behind the shrub yeah but
he didn't have any lights down there for
me on purpose so i couldn't
i couldn't talk to nobody so i don't
want to hear
i want to hear i didn't know him then
yeah and i had
and i had to pay uh 2700 a month oh
i stayed there about two weeks he kept
my deposit i cleaned the place and
everything
yeah so so that's the other side of
science that's the dirty side of the
dirt that's the
dark side the dark side good afternoon
and other times thanks for watching that
video you just saw
i mean it was okay but the next video
you can watch
could be way better what if you watch a
video right now that changes
your life well you could watch this one
or watch this one
watch this one watch this one watch this
one